[Applause]
[Music]
these are sequences from a plane called
the Lehmann trilogy which traces the
origins of Western capitalism in three
hours with three actors and a piano and
my role was to create a stage design to
write a visual language for this work
the play describes Atlantic crossings
Alabama cotton fields New York skylines
and we framed the whole thing within
this single revolving cubed a kind of
kinetic cinema through the centuries
it's like a musical instrument played by
three performers and as they step their
way around and through the lives of the
Leland brothers we the audience begin to
connect with the simple human origins at
the root of the complex global financial
systems that we're all still in thrall
to today I used to play musical
instruments myself when I was younger my
favorite was the violin it was this
intimate transfer of energy you held
this organic sculpture up to your heart
and you poured the energy of your whole
body into this little piece of wood and
heard it translated into music and I was
never particularly good at the violin
but I used to sit at the back of the
second violin section in the Hastings
Youth Orchestra scratching away we were
all scratching and marveling at this
symphonic sound that we were making that
was so much more beautiful and powerful
than anything we would ever have managed
on our own and now as I create
large-scale performances I'm always
working with teams that are at least the
size of a symphony orchestra and whether
we are creating these revolving giant
chess piece
time tunnels for an opera by Richard
Wagner or shark tanks and mountains for
Kanye West we're always seeking to
create the most articulate sculpture the
most poetic instrument of communication
to an audience when I say poetic
I just mean language at its most
condensed like a song lyric a poetic
puzzle to be unlocked and unpacked and
when we were preparing to design
Beyonce's formation tour we looked at
all the lyrics and we came across this
poem that Beyonce wrote I saw a TV
preacher when I was scared at 4 or 5
about bad dreams who promised he'd say a
prayer if I put my hand to the TV that's
the first time I remember prayer as an
electric current running through me and
this TV that transmitted prayer to
Beyonce as the child became this
monolithic revolving sculpture that
broadcast Beyonce to the back of the
stadium and the stadium is a mass
congregation it's a temporary population
of a hundred thousand people who've all
come there to sing along with every word
together but they've also come there
each seeking one-to-one intimacy with
the performer and we as we conceive the
show we have to provide intimacy on a
grand scale it usually starts with
sketches I was drawing this 60 foot high
revolving broadcast-quality portrait of
the artist and then I tore the piece of
paper in half I split the mask to try to
access the human underneath it all and
it's one thing to do sketches but of
course translating from a sketch into a
Torah ball revolving six storey building
took some exceptional engineers working
around the clock for three months until
finally we arrived in Miami and opened
the show in April 2016
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I call my work thank you
I call my work stage sculpture but of
course what's really being sculpted is
the experience of the audience and as
directors and designers we have to take
responsibility for every minute that the
audience spend with us we're a bit like
pilots navigating a flight path for a
hundred thousand passengers and in the
case of the Canadian artist The Weeknd
we translated this flight path literally
into an origami paper folding aeroplane
that took off over the heads of the
audience broke apart in mid-flight
complications and then rose out of the
ashes restored at the end of the show
and like any flight the most delicate
part is the lift off the beginning
because when you design a pop concert
the prime material that you're working
with is something that doesn't take
trucks or crew to transport it it
doesn't cost anything and yet it feels
every atom of air in the arena before
the show starts it's the audience's
anticipation everyone brings with them
the story of how they came to get there
the distances they traveled the months
they had to work to pay for the tickets
sometimes they sleep overnight outside
the arena and our first task is to
deliver for an audience on their
anticipation to deliver their first
sight of the performer when I work with
men they're quite happy to have their
music transformed into metaphor
spaceflights mountains but with women we
work a lot with masks and with
three-dimensional portraiture because
the fans of the female artists crave her
face and when the audience arrived to
see Adele's first live concert in five
years they were met with this image of
her eyes asleep if they listen carefully
they would hear her sleeping breath
echoing around the arena waiting to wake
up here's how the show began
[Applause]
with you too we're navigating the
audience over a terrain that spans three
decades of politics poetry and music and
over many months meeting with the band
and their creative teams this is the
sketch that kept recurring this line
this street the street that connects the
band's past with their present the
tightrope that they walk as activists
and artists a walk through cinema that
allows the bands to become protagonists
in their own poetry
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the end of the show was like the end of
a flight it's an arrival it's a transfer
from the stage out to the audience for
the British band take that we ended the
show by sending an 80-foot high
mechanical human figure out to the
center of the crowd
[Applause]
like many translations from music to
mechanics this one was initially deemed
entirely technically impossible the
first three engineers we took it to said
no and eventually the way that it was
achieved was by keeping the entire
control system together while it toured
around the country so we had to fold it
up onto a flatbed truck so it could tour
around without coming apart and of
course what this meant was that the
dimension of its head was entirely
determined by the lowest motorway bridge
that it had to travel under on its tour
and I have to tell you that it turns out
there is an unavoidable and annoyingly
low bridge just outside Hamburg
[Music]
another of the most technically complex
pieces that we've worked on is the opera
Carmen that brigands festival in Austria
we envisaged Carmen's hands rising out
of Lake Constance and throwing this deck
of cards in the air and leaving them
suspended between sky and sea but this
transient gesture this flick of the
wrists had to become a structure that
would be strong enough to withstand two
Austrian winters so there's an awful lot
that you don't see in this photograph
that's working really hard it's a lot of
ballast and structure and support around
the back and I'm I'm going to show you
the photos that aren't on my website
they're photos of the back of a set the
part that's not designed for the
audience to see however much work it's
doing and you know this is actually the
dilemma for an artist who's working as a
stage designer because so much of what I
make is fake
it's an illusion and yet every artist
works in pursuit of communicating
something that's true but we are always
asking ourselves can we communicate
truth using things that are false and
now when I attend the shows that I've
worked on I often find I'm the only one
who's not looking at the stage I'm
looking at something that I find equally
as fascinating and it's the audience we
were asked to witness this this many
humans connected focused undistracted
and unfragmented and lately I've begun
to make work that originates here in the
collective voice of the audience poem
portraits is a collective poem it began
at the serpentine gallery in London and
everybody is invited to donate one word
to a collective poem and instead of that
large single led poetry that was
broadcasting to the back of the stadium
in this case every member of the
audience gets to take their own poetry
at home with them and it's woven in with
the words that they've contributed to
the collective poem so they keep a
fragment of an ever-evolving collective
work and next year the collective poem
will take architectural form this is the
design for the UK Pavilion at the World
Expo 2020 the UK in my lifetime it's
never felt this divided it's never felt
this noisy with divergent voices and
it's never felt this much in lead of
places where voices might connect and
convergent is my hope that this wooden
sculpture this wooden instrument a bit
like that violin I used to play might be
a place where people can play and enter
their word at one end of the cone emerge
at the other end of the building and
find that their word has joined a
collective poem a collective voice
[Music]
these are simple experiments in machine
learning the algorithm that generates
the collective poem is pretty simple
it's it's like predictive text only it's
trained on millions of words written by
poets in the 19th century so it's a sort
of convergence of intelligence past and
present organic and inorganic and we
were inspired by the words of Stephen
Hawking towards the end of his life he
asked quite a simple question if we as a
species were ever to come across another
advanced life-form an advanced
civilization how would we speak to them
what collective language would we speak
as a planet the language of lights
reaches every audience all of us are
touched by it none of us can hold it and
in the theater we begin each work in a
dark place devoid of light we stay up
all night focusing the lights
programming the lights trying to find
new ways to sculpt and carve light
[Music]
this is a portrait
of our practice always seeking new ways
to shape and reshape light always
finding words the things that we no
longer need to say and I want to say
that this and everything that I've just
shown you no longer exists in physical
form in fact most of what I've made over
the last 25 years doesn't exist anymore
but our working jaws in memories in
synaptic sculptures in the minds of
those who were once present in the
audience I once read that a poem learnt
by heart is what you have left what
can't be lost even if your house burns
down and you've lost all your
possessions I want to end with some
lines that I learnt by heart a long time
ago they're written by the English
novelists Iain Foster in 1910 just a few
years before Europe my continent began
tearing itself apart and his quarter
convergence still resonates through most
of what we're trying to make now only
connect it was the whole of her sermon
only connect the prose and the passion
and both will be exalted and human love
will be seen at its height only connect
and live in fragments no longer thank
you
[Applause]